[Musique]
goodrich
amirouche bonsoir à tous et merci de
votre écoute attentif sur le sujet que
je vais essayer de vous transmettre avec
plutôt mon coeur qui m'a tête
parfois ils vont pas ensemble enfin on
va essayer si vous êtes bienveillant
avec moi donc l' équilibre déséquilibre
bon vous voyez je pense dans l'image
c'est toujours difficile dans nos
sociétés mais chez les femmes ça reste
quand même bien année c'est donc tout ce
qu'on doit jongler moi je vous parle
quand même dans mon histoire je suis né
au brésil
vous avez compris avec son bouddha repos
derrière en dictature militaire en 1973
le sport dans mon pays c'est une
religion
moi j'étais plutôt une hérésie bon
pourtant je travaille dans le sport
aujourd'hui est par contre tout les
performances liées à la pratique
physique cette notion d'arrivée en
premier d'être mieux que tout le monde
qu'on a appris quand je courais avec des
crampons j'ai n'ai pas appris en
pratiquant avec mes coaches militaire
j'ai appris plus tôt avec un collectif
de femmes qui étaient les femmes qui
m'ont élevé qui étaient solidaires sous
tenante encourageantes
pauvre même misérable il manquait
beaucoup de choses c'est pas grave à
tout va bien se passer
c'est bien fini n'ayez pas pitié de moi
je suis plutôt bien aux formes
aujourd'hui et ces femmes là elles m'ont
transmis cette notion de solidarité d'un
corrige mans de valeurs du sport les
vraies valeurs du sport c'est
l'inclusion c'est faire partie
faire participer tout le monde dans une
action commune dans le collectif
et aujourd'hui vous imagine que vous
avez tous vécu cette sensation un moment
donné dans votre vie de ne pas faire
partie ne pas être inclus d'être exclue
verte à l'extérieur la petite boule à
qui va pas bien elle n'est pas contente
elle est triste et on peut avec les
valeurs sportif transformer la donne
ramener l'un clusif en choisissant là où
on veut y aller comme on veut y aller
avec qui on voyait les donc je plaide
aujourd'hui pour la non-mixité inclusif
et soutenant et fort de ce soutien
je voudrais vous proposer de regarder
ces déséquilibres qui sont donc la place
je saute pas ce qu'on me dit qu' il
fallait pas faire des allers-retours
donc j'essaie de me placer là où je peux
ça va vous êtes avec moi oui
donc là les valeurs fin l'aller les
déséquilibres est aujourd'hui sept
garçons pratique de l'activité physique
dans les quartiers sensibles et une
fille ne pratique pas passer sept
garçons aujourd'hui c'est 93 %
d'émissions sportives qui concerne la
pratique masculine et la compétition 82%
des compétiteurs ce sont des hommes 12,7
pour cent des femmes son dirigeant dans
le mouvement sportif
57% des femmes dont toute la france ne
sont pas en accord avec leur corps pour
se sentir bien dans la pratique physique
parce que le sport il est toujours
associé très souvent à la compétition et
la performance
moi je viens de vous parler du sport
plaisir inclusif possible et pour ça je
me suis armé d'une collectif de femmes
ce sont 200 femmes aujourd'hui ce sont
des publics diversifiés ont fait
quatorze cours dans la métropole c'est
tout d'horizon tout les âges des
quartiers prioritaires dans lequel on se
balade parce qu'on est une association
nomades on a décidé de ne pas avoir le
lieu parce qu'on n'a pas de moyens mais
aussi parce que on veut voyager
donc on va à droite et à gauche
peut-être qui parmi vous si on avait des
moyens toute façon vont au cinéma
il est autonome et indépendante parce
que c'est notre objectif c'est une
fédération sportive composée de 92 % de
femmes
ses dix membres bénévoles c'est du
partage et l'autre rêve
notre ambition c'est de former des
éducatrices et sportif nous avons aussi
des projets partenaires dans lequel on
travaille avec la santé mentale
on travaille avec les sdf les mineurs
isolés les réfugiés toujours dans cette
logique d'inclusion de chercher chez
l'autre quelque chose qu'on n'a
peut-être pas pour nous changer
et là dessus je voulais vous inviter à
sentir à sentir des vibrations dans
votre coeur et dans votre esprit avec
mes racines et j'ai envie tu mon avis
bisaro bon mes racines elles sont un peu
cassé aujourd'hui au brésil
mais bon ils sont là quand même merci de
l'accueillir chaleureusement
[Applaudissements]
laissez vous porter par la vibration
[Musique]
ça va venir ou taper des pieds
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
brigade le visage valeo est maintenant
que ce coeur chez l'autre les chevaux
vous il a serré il a pris de l'émotion
je vais vous ramenez maintenant dont
mais elle je vous demande d'accueillir
chaleureusement kamel
[Applaudissements]
je vais vous demander de mettre la main
sur votre coeur et vous laisser emporter
par l'autre qui vous emmène en voyage
chez vous
[Musique]
merci quand même
merci infiniment
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors maintenant que j'aimerais que père
autour des racines et des ailes de mes
racines et des ailes dans ce sens en
vous dans ce que vous ressentez avec
votre coeur qui je voulais vous
présenter la présidente de mon
association et la vice-présidente l'oci
et fatou des femmes s'unissent pour
porter un projet un projet de inclusion
par le sport dans sa diversité et dans
sa beauté ce que vous avez ressenti ce
que vous regardez passerelle c'est aussi
une team ton adina on a six îles en à
simone emilie sonia olivia fatoumata et
bénédicte qui portent l'idée d'une
inclusion nos mixte par la pratique
physique pour défendre ses idées j'ai
besoin d'autres éducateurs qui puisse
suivre le chemin donc on expérimentait
bompard dont j'ai oublié de parler
douanes pour immelt
évidemment il y a une notion de
importante qui est un moment hyper
compliqué de traduire en français
j'ai inventé impôts des romans il
n'existe pas mais si chacun de vous vous
pouvez le répéter peut-être qu'on peut
le mettre au larousse un veau
d'errements ça va en vo d'airé c'est
compréhensible
oui vous y êtes là on sont peu d'air en
faut des rémois là j'ai besoin
allez je besoin de votre abba ou merci
yes
donc j'ai sauté du sujet parce que mon
corps et les parties ma tête je ne suis
plus à l'été il y à aussi l'envi de
démocratiser la bicyclette
c'est un formidable ça donc on va aller
faire des cures de bicyclette à lille
sud
pour l'instant on est en sécurité dans
un siècle fait mais pour apprendre à
monter dans la bicyclette ce que
j'essaye de leur dire c'est que pour l'
équilibre on ne marche pas comme ça on
ne marche pas comme ça non plus donc de
ce fait elle montre la musique latine
ont jamais monté sur la bicyclette avant
mais aujourd'hui elles peuvent aller
faire des courses
y aller chercher leurs enfants à l'école
en bicyclette avec toute leur diversité
c'est joli une femme en bicyclette et
ont lors d'un à certification fin donc
bicyclette on nous démocratisation de la
bicyclette mais évidemment pour ce faire
j'ai souhaité un moment voilà il me faut
des compagnons de travail une équipe on
a proposé une formation sportif avec la
fédération française des sports et gym
volontaire dont les quartiers sensibles
l'idée c'était la faire non mixtes mais
on m'a imposé la mixité donc les deux
jeunes filles que vous voyez elle son
assise légale sont forts ils montrent
qu'ils sont beaux qu'ils sont puissants
ils étaient dans la notion de il
imaginait que le métier d'éducateur
sportif c'était faire dix mille pompe
mais en fait c'est pas ça du tout c'est
comprendre l'autre dans ses besoins et
l'amener plus loin de ce fait cette
formation elle a eu lieu il ya une
partie des garçons qui ont reçu leur
diplôme
mais les filles elles ont arrêté au
milieu et donc aujourd'hui l'histoire du
prix le seul prix que j'ai eu dans ma
vie pour le sport je suis très contente
d'ailleurs c'est de pouvoir plaider sur
la non mixité choisi et inclusif donc
j'ai proposé il y à un mois à services
institutionnels d'état est d'ailleurs me
soutiennent sur l'action j'espère que
vous allez me soutenir russie sur la
formation des jeunes filles dans les
quartiers politique de la ville des
quartiers sensibles dans le métier
d'éducateur sportif pour essaimer
l'inclusion par le sport et partager
cette diversité fabuleuse qui nous
vivons dans notre pays
fantastique qu'est la france je crois
que vous êtes tous d'accord avec moi
j'espère donc c'est une première étape
vers l'inclusion
mais je sais qu'on peut mieux faire on
peut toujours mieux faire
1 on peut mieux faire
on peut mieux faire au premier vingt bon
on va essayer un corps a qu'un petit peu
d'enthousiasmé comme ça je vais vous et
j'essaye de passer ce que je ressens
donc ok à 2,3 on peut bien faire
bon c'est un petit peu le mot de la fin
j'ai pas terminée parce que j'ai encore
un petit peu de minutes donc je vais
quand même profiter de cette de cette
plénière pour pouvoir vous dire quelque
chose donc on peut marcher vers le mieux
vivre ensemble à partir du moment qu'on
accepte les choix de tout un chacun dans
une diversité inclusive et que le mot
liberté égalité fraternité garde tout
son sens
on peut le faire je suis sûr qu'on peut
le faire
yes merci
[Applaudissements]